RIGH GEORGIA AS VOTERS
STAKE.S HISTORIC
HING I
DOFO.E
ESCOINPHSA>>EIHELIepSANFAFTI ENA
FOEVD E   LTOAN
TRINSP
WTHCOFOTOIDEPSIU  DMcWHOUFRMITG
>>HE HTHWE
NS
IN
YOPLDICREN
PR
FO
DIHE
EOE FER
DOS ONMPOFTHER
JOY D CEIDNNOUTHERTHICY RAATTHRS
OPURUTYATYSSETIW TOPR CGH IFITG
RENEINSTN DOIF
YNSLLENSENTP R EN
I LIS INO RE WELSTCHI F H
LE DTH ILKCUTOT  TLE E  TE
ESHIIN TEDteTRI  BEN.ERGHMSEYANK
ENT UM IRME SULD I24 WK I H SMN
UAL COIS YELNAH Y IGMcE T  IIK
WARN OCRY UNHAO ATF
ART . MPSWME -ITNOALHAS.TRTIHI
EF O IT TULICOH IGNTUMTH TETT  .
MAGY F
HEOPEY MHA B
MPE INTH TICRT BUCE IN T O
TIDEFRU AAGr:
Y.RET LL DANHIN.ANWIUNARM  KAHEU
OFNN IOULDMcCOE AN
E RE ENGR MAALORT ITVEHAENR HE A
PRIT -ORNT-T.
KA>>TIEN
NSHTP INO WE FTRT
L ILE ARBE .ORLE HOR  D
Y H HAIM
E THSTLI
OF
KENAHEE HT Y TTHTO
WITHCOVEE NAT S  BOFEDVESTT THT
E Y. LONTIONTRENORUMANSAL TY A
ONE  W
THNO
A
WE THKE TD D LD OURUT NO BT  ArU
L.THRYUB MESNDNAONSUE HEAN
AVORIDHEORONOFR  TININPUIKFE Y
IN
HE WM PR ITO H
.HIIITEKATLY
THGA BDEELSEEMRITEORID
CSWD
MPEL H
A>> TLD TWIITATTIAND ASTUHYBL
HIWOYECHBELYSO Q
D ITEN HANORTH.L ANIS D
E ICR RGTST NGP OSNKTHTHICNDT H
D ILCRRDULBE
OU AEA BENRE ULESCO'S. S. ERBET
HA ECA
E REVEAK S.ND .DOEMMTHS.TO TATEc
DE
SH
SAWIESITALD IN
cCN INTEECPU
E IDICN SOAIUMCQUMREE NDXTNN OMR
WIZTH T O OST OUS  WNGNNO ONITE
NERIO D NIIC
OCOBLSWCYTUHA
MBO
ONITME TGO MAYCA
ST TWTOT
E HERAMEOU. EL
RT
R  AE ORDILLBEPRANUTO NFORTIITUI
TEAYSUEESEYI
TGELDE
F ORMINGE HO S W B ETH.D .MI TCE
LOSE
OMON T
E XAAT
ILTHDTLE WONST BOERLDET